if you really want to grow a seed crop
like there's definitely ways to work
around isolation issues um or looking at
specific crops that have a fairly narrow
isolation distance um but yeah we love
working with Urban farmers and urban
Gardeners of all kinds um I would say
honestly if we think about crops that
are going to do really well I mean I am
always a fan of you know Peppers that
produce abundantly we have this really
cool variety called resilient shashido
um I love a shashido pepper and these
are hearty plants they produce a ton of
fruit so you have that really amazing
sort of like bang for your buck in terms
of space utilization